In the mid-1800s, a group of archaeologists
from England embarked on an expedition to
Mongolia.
The expedition was headed by Jonathan Davis,
his long-term research partner Jason Porter,
and their assistant, Marvin Thomas.
With them, they brought a ship, all the necessary
equipment, and a team of ten workers to aid
with the dig and the transportation of any
relics back to the British Isles.
There, they found a number of historically
significant artifacts, one of which was described
in Davis’s journal as
“A most marvelous discovery the likes of
which the world has never known!
It will surely be regarded as the crown jewel
of our findings, and I delight at the thought
of what ancient secrets it may allow us to
uncover!”
Unfortunately for him, he would never get
to find out.
When the ship arrived back on the shores of
England, those waiting for its return discovered
that every single man on board was dead.
Their mangled bodies littered the deck of
the ship, and Johnathan Davis’s head had
been torn clean off.
Whatever had killed them, it was far stronger
than all thirteen men combined.
Given the unusual circumstances of these deaths,
the artifacts were seized by The Oddities,
Occult, and Paranormal Society, or OOPS - one
of the many groups started by stuffy English
gentlemen of the era that mainly functioned
as a glorified cabinet of curiosities - and
placed in their Inner Sanctum.
The largest, and most impressive of these,
was a large black stone cube, covered with
strange symbols, which they displayed prominently
for several years, until one day, the same
dark force that killed the archaeologists
on their own ship stirred once more.
Something escaped from within the stone, killing
everyone present in the Inner Sanctum and
leaving a trail of more bodies in its wake
until eventually, it was apprehended by the
SCP Foundation, placed in containment, and
designated SCP-076.
SCP-076 consists of two separate components:
a stone cube, SCP-076-1, and the humanoid
contained inside of the cube, or SCP-076-2.
SCP-076-1 is a three-meter cube of black metamorphic
stone, covered in patterned engravings that
have not been matched to any known civilization.
Analysis via radioisotope suggests that the
cube is at least ten thousand years old, though
an exact date of origin could not be determined.
There is a door on one side, sealed with a
lock surrounded by twenty smaller locks, all
arranged in a circular pattern.
The Foundation has not been able to locate
any of the keys, and therefore is unable to
lock the door.
This is unfortunate, given the nature of the
figure that lurks inside the cube, chained
inside of a stone coffin.
This is the resting place of SCP-076-2, also
known as Able.
Able is a humanoid male who appears to be
in his late twenties, with black hair, gray
eyes, and olive skin.
In spite of his youthful appearance, his age
is estimated to be around the same as the
cube that holds him.
His body is covered in tattoos, depicting
various occult icons and images of demonic
faces - not uncommon for warrior castes of
old.
When he is encased in his coffin, within his
stone prison, Able is technically dead and
registers no vital signs of any kind.
However, he does not stay dead.
On an occasional basis, with no apparent cause,
he will wake up and reanimate.
Once he is awake and aware, he will attempt
to leave the cube by any means necessary.
If he manages to escape, he will look for
the nearest human being and attempt to kill
them.
Once he has latched on to a target, he will
enter a rage state that will not stop until
he is killed.
Though, as his anomalous nature implies, this
death is never permanent, and he will always
awaken again eventually.
Terminating Able in order to stopone of his
rampages is often difficult, as he possesses
strength and durability far beyond the capabilities
of an ordinary man.
He has superhuman power and speed, and, though
his physical body can be damaged, he does
not appear to respond to pain and continues
to fight through extreme injuries that would
take most targets down.
During his time in Foundation custody, he
has displayed the following abilities:
Over the course of four minutes, while trying
to attack a Research Assistant that happened
to cross into his line of sight moments before,
he ripped through a reinforced steel security
door with his bare hands, breaking the steel
apart as if it were layers of tin foil.
During another incident, he was able to run
a distance of 64 meters in under three seconds
to catch up to an armored van filled with
Foundation guards.
While security staff attempted to neutralize
him during the same incident, he took several
.50 caliber rounds to the head and continued
to move and kill for several minutes after,
in spite of having literal holes in his head
and missing portions of vital brain matter.
During another escape, he got ahold of a piece
of steel rebar which he used to swat bullets
from handguns and assault rifles out of the
air, like he was batting a ball with a tennis
racket.
During another attempted escape, after killing
a half dozen D-Classes along the way, Foundation
staff were eventully able to trap the entity
in a vat of water, sealing the top, where
he tread water furiously for an hour before
eventually suffocating.
This suggests that, unlike most people who
will asphyxiate after only a few minutes without
oxygen, he can survive for at least an hour.
The most notable of his anomalous skills,
however, is his ability to produce weapons,
usually bladed, from thin air whenever he
wants to.
Slowed-down security footage has shown that
he does this by pulling the weapons out of
a tiny rift in space, a portal to another
dimension of some kind.
It is unsure where this portal leads to, or
how Able accesses it, but it appears to function
as his own personal armory, stocked with an
endless supply of black, non-reflective bladed
weapons, which vanish as soon as they leave
his grasp.
Though it is difficult and often dangerous
to do so, Able can in fact be killed.
Some previously effective methods of termination
have included: fire from multiple heavy-caliber
machine guns, suffocation, being crushed beneath
a 13.6 metric ton piece of elevator equipment,
cremation via a grenade placed inside of a
cavity in his chest, and the detonation of
an on-site nuclear warhead.
Every time SCP-076-2 is killed, his corpse
quickly decays at an unnaturally rapid rate
until it has turned into a pile of dust.
Then, the door to the cube, as well as the
coffin inside, will slam shut, and the lock
on the outside will rotate shut.
Somehow, Able’s body will then reform inside
the coffin.
This process can take anywhere from six hours
to over 20 years.
After a series of failed experiments, containment
procedures for SCP-076 were amended to the
current procedures in place.
SCP-076 is placed in Containment Area 25b,
located 200 meters below sea level, tunneled
into solid bedrock in an area with limited
seismic activity.
The only way to access this area is via an
elevator shaft, which is broken up every 50
meters with a reinforced blast door made of
shielding that is 20 cm thick.
When the elevator shaft is not being used,
it is flooded with seawater.
The containment area includes an outer security
perimeter outfitted with security personnel
trained in counter-intrusion and close-quarters
combat, an Administrative and Support area
where on-site personnel can live and rest,
a Primary Containment Zone filled with seawater
and made of a 7m cube encased in reinforced
material, and then, a “killing corridor”
that is 150 meters in size, with an electrical
system able to deliver a 20,000-volt shock
in the event of an attempted containment breach.
The security station at the entrance of the
killing corridor must be staffed with at least
three armed security guards at all times.
In the event of a containment breach, all
staff on-site must go to the closest security
station immediately for weapons and armor.
The staff will remain at Alert Condition One
until Able has been neutralized and re-contained.
If 90 minutes pass after a full breach without
the order to Stand Down being given, the entire
facility will be flooded with seawater and
the access shaft will be sealed for 24 hours.
This is considered an extreme measure, as
it will kill any site staff present, but desperate
times call for desperate measures.
After the containment procedures were amended,
and the file updated, Dr [Redacted] submitted
a complaint to Director Maria Jones, head
of Recordkeeping and Information Security
Administration.
The correspondence reads as follows:
“I have to go on record as saying that I
seriously object to the proposed revisions
of the SCP-076 Special Containment Procedures
File.
I know that Redact All Important Stuff Already
claims it's a security risk, but you and I
both know it's just top brass trying to sweep
their biggest and most embarrassing mistake
ever under the rug.
Omega-Seven happened.
It existed.
Those people died because you screwed up,
and you can't change that, no matter how hard
you try to hide it.
For God's sake, man, those people guarding
him deserve to know exactly what he is and
what he did.
What WE did.
How we screwed up, so they'll know better.”
So what was Omega-Seven?
What could have possibly constituted one of
the Foundation’s worst, greatest, most humiliating
mistakes ever?
Following the death of an Agent, whose identity
has been redacted, who had managed to best
Able several times in combat, the Foundation
became aware of an intriguing possibility:
Whenever Able encountered the rare individual
he perceived as superior, or at least equal,
to him in combat, his uncontrollable rage
would subside and he would develop a kind
of respect.
When Able learned of the man’s death, he
calmed down and was coherent enough to interview.
He was distressed at the death, which had
occurred as collateral damage in an airstrike
intended to contain another SCP.
He explained his feelings on the subject:
“A man like that deserves to die in combat,
so close to his opponent he can feel his breath.
Not in some destruction ordered by cowardly
kings and princes safe in their palaces.
The rest of you…you disgust me.
I don't even have the urge to strike you down.”
After this interview, the Researcher who conducted
it recommended that the Foundation attempt
to find a way to work with Able, and somehow
militarize him in accordance with the Bowe
Commission’s desire to use SCP objects for
tactical purposes.
A Mobile Task Force was proposed, referred
to as “Omega-7” or by its nickname “Pandora’s
Box.”
Task Force Omega-Seven was to consist of between
ten and twenty field agents, split up into
teams of three and five people each.
Members of these teams have selected a roster
of highly qualified field agents, and chosen
by Able himself.
Their purpose would be to provide support
to him during high-risk fieldwork and combat-based
situations.
Able was outfitted with a device attached
to his neck that, if it was triggered or interfered
with in any way, would detonate and destroy
his spinal cord, trachea, and the major blood
vessels of his neck, killing him instantly.
A tracking device was also attached to Able,
in order to keep the Foundation informed of
his whereabouts at all times.
Able was instructed to refrain from any unnecessary
killing or violence, and only attack when
ordered to.
This operation was off to a bit of a rocky
start, and the head researcher in charge of
it added this addendum to the initial project
proposal:
“For God's sake, find these guys something
to do.
Able's getting bored, and he's started putting
his team through live-fire exercises: they
get bullets, he gets training weapons.
Have you ever seen someone break a man's jaw
using a Nerf sword?
He's not gonna stop until someone gets killed.”
Indeed, Able was getting restless, and the
Foundation needed to find a way to keep him
busy until he could be occupied with bloodier
pursuits.
This project report was submitted regarding
Able’s activities:
“In light of SCP-076-2's proficient use
of the Sumerian language, researchers have
asked it to translate several documents.
While it originally replied with disinterest,
it has translated some of the documents it
found worthy of its attention.
Most of the documents chosen by SCP-076-2
were regarding battles or legendary heroes,
one of its favorites in particular being the
"Epic of Gilgamesh".
However, one researcher presented it with
the symbol from SCP-073.
Upon sight of this, SCP-076-2 became highly
enraged, killing several of the researchers
before its kill switch could be activated.
When revived and questioned about this, SCP-076-2
responded aggressively, and that line of questioning
was immediately dropped.
It is recommended anything pertaining to SCP-073
never be brought to the attention of SCP-076-2
and that the two are never to be in the same
facility.”
Eventually, the chance to see Omega-Seven
in action came about, and Able and his task
force were deployed at the request of the
Bowe Commission.
Though the details have been redacted from
the official file, the mission was deemed
a success, and General Bowe thanked the research
team in an email with the subject line “A
Job Well Done”.
He wrote: “Excellent work, doctor.
The mission went exactly as expected.
We'll be calling you again if we need your
help.”
This new chapter of the project bred discord
between the two lead researchers assigned
to Able, from here on referred to as Dr. W
and Dr. P. Dr. P was highly in favor of Omega-Seven
and its military applications, while Dr. W
strongly disapproved, believing the project
to be an example of the military forcing the
SCP Foundation to do its dirty work.
He responded to the General’s congratulations
with a strongly worded email to his colleague,
too strongly worded to repeat here.
To summarize it neatly: he was very upset.
Following this email, and at Dr. P’s request,
Dr. W was reassigned to SCP-682, leaving him
as the sole researcher in charge of the Omega-Seven
project.
After a series of incidents regarding friendly
fire and casualties within the task force
itself, most of which occurred during ordinary
combat training, Dr. P sent an email to the
General:
“Despite our best efforts, Subject Able
is proving difficult to control.
All our attempts to keep him engaged have
been more or less unsuccessful.
The problem is, he's a perfect killing machine,
and that's all he wants to do.
Which seems like exactly what we wanted, but
the problem is, we can't seem to turn him
off.
I'm running out of missions to give him, and
the ones I've got left aren't engaging him
mentally.
He's starting to lash out at the other team
members.
It's only a matter of time before something
goes wrong.
Requesting permission to discontinue the project
and neutralize Able temporarily, until we
can find something more for him to do.”
The General refused to agree to this: “Unacceptable.
Neutralizing Subject Able at this point is
going to cause us an unacceptable delay.
We'll have another mission for you within
a couple of weeks.
All you have to do is keep him busy until
then.
Send him on vacation or something.”
Dr. P was stunned by this response, and unsure
how to proceed.
Not only was there nowhere safe to send Able
on vacation, short of firing him into the
furthest recesses of outer space where he
could not hurt anyone, he was simply not a
man interested in leisure, rest, or vacation
as a concept.
They had let the tiger out of its cage, and
now all it wanted to do was shred, bite, and
kill.
He tried to keep Able occupied, burning through
D-Class on a daily basis that he could use
as human practice dummies, but eventually
Able’s craving for a challenge became too
strong.
An automated alert went out to the staff of
the site where Able was contained, signaling
the start of a state of emergency:
“SCP-076-2 has disabled the explosive collar
failsafe and gone out of control.
All staff to high alert.
Further requests as events warrant.”
There is no surviving security footage from
this incident, and there are no witnesses
to recount what happened next.
Here is what we know for sure: Sometime after
Able escaped from his explosive collar, Containment
Area 25 began the ten-minute countdown for
its on-site nuclear warhead.
No staff were able to successfully evacuate
before the warhead detonated, reducing the
site to rubble.
Site 67 and 68 activated FEMA protocol and
secured the location.
Meanwhile, the stone coffin sealed itself
again, the lock clicked shut, and Able began
to rebuild from almost nothing.
Ashes to ashes, as they say.
And dust to dust.
Following this, a revised psychological profile
of the entity was submitted:
“SCP-076-2 either possesses a mind constructed
much differently than our own, or is completely
insane, with little empathy or ideas in a
way that we would understand it.
Concepts such as sex, love, and equality are
completely foreign ideas to SCP-076-2, or
at least in comparison to its way of viewing
them.
Subject has shown that it is completely disinterested
in sex, barely differentiating between genders
except as a form of visual identification.
Also, while subject seems to greatly enjoy
the act of killing, causing pain - either
emotionally or physically - holds no attraction
to it.
Intelligence tests have been wildly inconclusive
when applied to SCP-076-2, and no accurate
result has yet been obtained.
This is due to the fact that no communication
is possible with the Subject when in its "rage"
state.
Subject displays knowledge of several languages
including English, but most notable is its
knowledge of several dialects of ancient Sumerian,
which seem to be its preferred language.
SCP-076 has nothing but contempt for human
beings and will kill them on sight.
No communication is to be attempted with the
subject.”
Now go check out “SCP-001 - Dark Truth About
The O5 Council” and “Top 15 Most Dangerous
SCP Monsters in Containment” for more deadly
secrets from inside the Foundation!